hi I'm Jeremy John's I don't know if any
of you are new to my channel if you are
I'm movie fan I love a good horror movie
I like leaving the movie theater and
going home and feeling like the movie
stays with you you know you start seeing
shadows you're laying in bed you start
seeing things you know I like that
feeling of theater in this world is
social media it's apparent that a lot of
filmmakers and producers they see tweets
and work that people like me do you know
people on YouTube people on Twitter
people on Facebook and there are any
directors out there who are looking to
make a good horror movie from me to you
I'd really like to ask you to please
stop making boring ass [ __ ] generic
horror movies
Oh a job I know it's Ouija do we jeez a
movie about a group of generic teenage
horror movie idiots one of their friends
dies so to communicate with her they
need to use a Ouija board but then they
contact some evil spirit now it's just
things are gonna get messy I want to say
that's the actual plot the real synopsis
is this sweet Jesus movie about a group
of generic teenage horror movie idiots
one of their friends dies and so they
mope around in high school and you know
there's got a deal with that [ __ ] and
the easy ways you board a couple times
that's really closer to the actual
synopsis of this movie series I like
consistency in things this movie is
consistently boring oh my god something
happened in this movie things happen in
this movie but they're that generic jump
scares are not scary when they're using
the Ouija board it is interesting like
ooh this is gonna go some work there
just doesn't go anywhere one time the
ghosts look freaks out and flips the
Ouija board up so it's like a high
school movie can do that [ __ ] hey high
school film student out there who makes
horror movies tell me you haven't done
the Ouija board flip thing you have and
that's fine for high school and I'm
paying like 12 bucks a ticket to see it
oh it's not I'll tell you some of the
reasons the intensity was gone in this
movie there was no tension there was no
intensity because nothing was really a
threat that it was just cheesy this is
one thing this dude looks in a mirror
you see the side profile of a ghost
woman's face but it was shitty looking
look like a ps1 CGI half profile face I
was like is that a ghost is that
supposed to be scary and then do gets
pushed into the mirror now here it is
the person in the movie like brace
himself in his hand hit the mirror when
he was pushed into the mirror it's not
scary that just tells me that if a ghost
attacks me I have time to brace myself
and not actually impact into the mirror
it'd be scarier fuze looking all sunny
she's cracked his face on the mirror
that makes me feel like when I'm
checking out the dental work I'm like oh
wait I don't want my face you could
smash into the mirror don't get too
close you see you got to make it real
for the audience here and I was saying
this is a spoiler alert I think it's a
rule of spoilers that you can't actually
spoil a shitty movie this is really the
nature of the ghost so I don't think
it's a spoiler the ghost just it kills
people these kids their eyes will turn
white and the ghost like hypnotizes them
and they commit suicide or that goes
like picks him up and slams him on the
ground in the crack their head and they
die that's not scary to me when you're
laying in bed you're afraid of the dark
you know you're full of [ __ ] maybe a
ghost is gonna come you're not afraid
that the ghost is going to come and kill
you you're afraid the ghost is gonna
torment you in the
and that's the real fear right there is
that this demon or this ghost or
whatever is gonna mess with you for
months weeks days whatever it is maybe
it'll scratch your body maybe it'll pull
you out of the bed maybe it'll drag you
to its lair by the foot I don't know but
if the ghost just quickly kills you it's
not actually scary generally speaking
fear of torture is scarier than fear of
death I assume that because when people
are getting tortured the classic thing
is eventually they'll ask the torturer
to please kill me right there we know
torture scarier than death
so if the ghost torments you and
tortures you that's scarier than the
ghost just killing you this ghost just
kills people so what not even in brutal
ways either ghost makes it pretty quick
pretty humane ghost really there's no
mind games the movie doesn't get in your
head and stay with you when you leave
the theater Ouija made me feel bad for
[ __ ] on Annabelle so much movies all
the boredom of Annabelle without the one
good scene that Annabelle had in the
basement Ouija feels about two and a
half hours long it has nothing in terms
of what you're looking for for a scary
movie or a horror movie or a ghost movie
none of it none of the characters matter
they're all generic as [ __ ] I'm not
saying you need good characters to be in
a horror movie I'm saying it helps if
your movies going to be boring and have
nothing that actually scares you I don't
know about you know everything I've seen
in my life but we geez definitely the
least scary ghost haunting movie I've
seen in 2014 sorry guys I feel like I'm
[ __ ] on ghost movies this year but
people filmmakers out there take that as
a sign make better [ __ ] because we G
definitely is dog [ __ ] oh man it felt
like three hours long was an hour and a
half so hauntings demons ghosts
situations like that do you believe in
that stuff you have a situation do you
have a story whatever it may be comment
below let me know I asked you that
because you're not gonna see Ouija so
I'm not even gonna ask you what you
think about it and as always if you like
what you seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more